let's go live now to ali latifi he's in
the eastern province of pakhtiya so the
authorities there appealing for
international more international aid are
they getting it though
they're slowly getting it earlier today
we saw world food program trucks passing
by we know that the international rescue
committee has started uh deploying
mobile medical units uh but the
assistance is still slow to come we're
currently at the paktya army corps and
here on this tarmac is where helicopters
will land and transport the injured to
ambulances that will then take them to
the regional hospital here but once they
get to the regional hospital here it's
another issue in that if the hospital
doesn't have proper emergency equipment
and it may not be able to treat head
injuries and so in that case they will
have to go by land to the city of kabul
which is another four or five hours away
so again it shows sort of in this
disaster setting the kinds of
shortcomings with which the government
is currently operating
now
what how much of a window of opportunity
exists to get aid in they're appealing
for help but people are trapped under
rubble right so every minute if not
every hour counts
it it's
exactly it's extremely urgent you know
we were talking to a pilot earlier who
was piloting one of the aircraft
and he was saying that when he lands in
pakico you know hundreds of people just
swarm towards the helicopter trying to
get their sick and injured on board
trying to get attention trying to get
out and get to a better hospital as much
as as much as possible and he was saying
that as many as the people who come and
seek help to get out into uh the city
the city of gazis there are just as many
still trapped under the rubble and
obviously the assistance was you know
hindered yesterday by the inclement
weather and then that also impacts you
know the condition of the people that
are being treated a lot of people may
have died just by being stuck under the
rubble others you know are facing
serious medical conditions because of
how long it's taking them to get to a
proper hospital whether that be in
galvez or if they have to be transported
to both
and as you're talking we were looking at
pictures next to you people were picking
through rubble with very basic
instruments it looked like what kind of
international help what kind of help or
aid or supplies
do they need there
so they need helicopters for sure uh
that that's one major issue is you know
helicopters come and go once every hour
or so but they can only take so many
people with them at a time so the more
they are there are because the roads are
so difficult to get to and because
yesterday you know there was rain and
hail that there would be uh flooding and
landslides and things like that they
really need air support at the moment
they also need as you said assistance in
terms of you know excavators and other
kinds of large-scale equipment to get
people out because people have been
trapped under the rubble since you know
very early yesterday morning at this
point
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much for that update ali latifi